-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you for watching.
Let's get to some news.
Well guys, today CNN officially
launched their brand new
streaming service, CNN Plus.
That's right.
With CNN Plus can you get news
from CNN all day at any time.
Or, as that's also known, CNN.
[ Laughter ]
But CNN is actually trying to
reach a younger audience
with their streaming service,
which explains why one show is
just Wolf Blitzer
playing Fortnite for an hour.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, CNN Plus
officially launched today.
That's right,
a whole streaming service
filled with CNN shows
and footage.
Check out some of the slogans
that they're testing out
to get people on board.
First, up there's "CNN Plus,
the airport bar experience
right on your phone."
[ Laughter ]
That's the only place I ever see
that and I go,
"Wow, that's a great show."
[ Light laughter ]
Next up there's "CNN Plus,
the most trusted name
in news, according to CNN.com"
[ Laughter ]
You said that?
And finally, there's
"CNN Plus,
your daily dose of anxiety,
now on mobile."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ugh! Oh, gosh! Send.
Let's switch gears. Guys,
everyone's talking about this.
The house committee
investigating the Capitol riot,
said that Trump's White House
phone records have a 7-hour gap
on January 6th.
Seven hours.
I don't know if anyone else is a
fan of the show "Dateline,"
but if your phone records are
missing even 10 minutes,
you're guilty.
[ Laughter ]
That's just --
"between 9:45 and 9:55,
Terrence didn't answer
his phone."
[ Light laughter ]
"He said he was taking a nap
that he always takes,
every night."
[ Light laughter ]
"At 9:45."
The only time there should be
a seven hour gap
is when you're trying to
remember what happened
on St. Patrick's day.
[ Light laughter ]
You put on a Dr. Seuss hat,
got on the train.
Yep, seven hours are missing,
yeah.
Even the ghost of Richard Nixon
is like,
"I don't think can you do that."
[ Laughter ]
And now after making the
discovery the house committee
is investigating whether Trump
used burner phones.
It's always reassuring when a
president acts like
a character in "The Wire."
You know what I'm saying?
[ Light laughter ]
Seriously, were they planning
an insurrection
or selling weed
to high school kids?
I don't -- I don't know which.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, after
President Biden's recent remark
that Putin cannot remain
in power,
a reporter asked Biden
if he thinks his comments
can cause Putin to escalate
his behavior.
Yeah, 'cause up until now Putin
has kept things pretty chill,
I think.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think anything
Biden says
is gonna change what Putin does.
It's like shouting to
a lion at the zoo.
It doesn't care
what you're saying.
If the lion can
get over that fake river,
you're going to get mauled.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
Fedex just announced
that after more than 50 years,
its founder and CEO
is stepping down.
[ Audience aws ]
Yep.
On his last day
he'll be driven home
and then thrown
on to his front lawn.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey!
-Of course he doesn't
want to lose touch,
so he gave all his coworkers his
tracking number, which is nice.
[ Laughter ]
You know where he is.
He's in Wisconsin right now,
he'll be home soon.
You gotta see this.
Apparently Verizon customers
have been receiving spam texts
from their own phone numbers.
[ Light laughter ]
It's weird when you get a text
from yourself at 2:00 a.m.
that says "Me up?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
AT&T customers are like,
"Ha ha,
that's what you get
for a company that has cell
service."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, listen to this.
I read that avocado prices have
skyrocketed to a 24-year high.
Man, did I pick the wrong time
to enjoy gasoline
over my avocado toast.
[ Laughter ]
Everything about it feels wrong.
[ Light laughter ]
Yep.
Everyone is looking for cheaper
options which explains this new
jingle I saw today.
♪ Avocados from
New Jersey ♪
There you go, 'ey!
[ Laughter ]
"I got your avocados
right here."
-"A couple of 'em, 'ey."
-And finally, police say the
general manager of a Denny's
in Pennsylvania embezzled over
$200,000 from the restaurant.
[ Audience ohs ]
It's serious.
If charged,
the manager could face 10 years
in the grand slammer.
There you go--
[ Laughter ]
We have a great show.